seven high schoolers decide who wins a
thousand dollars i'm here today
with the beautiful i don't want to call
you that yeah well that's okay it's just
the truth beautiful go ahead fine oh
fine as well
beautiful and fine stop
brand to react oh all right all right
you think stuff about the video and
possibly laugh at my jokes all right
okay i'll be your wingman
i'm your support
no you can say whatever you want hey the
floor is yours oh
oh i got nothing i don't know make a
joke okay great
anyway seven high schoolers decides to
win a thousand dollars have you seen
this video
no no i haven't okay me neither they
need to take these thousand dollars and
buy themselves some new clothes look at
these pants these
whole knees are hanging out that's such
a boomer joke and i feel like i was just
about to make the same
what these kids can't even afford
i'm curious what their uh what their
sappy stories are gonna be like well
let's watch
i think we should describe everyone's
situation first of all well i just don't
want anybody to leave with their
feelings hurt or feeling like
my problems aren't big enough and i feel
ashamed for talking about what i well no
one will feel you know
well you don't know that though gotcha
well i like how like they're they're all
in their feelings
they're all talking they're like oh my
god oh yeah i mean you know one thing
you're doing because i'm so considerate
of your feelings about that money you
know
me maybe i will start a youtube channel
it's not really a thing yet but
trust me let's plays are really cool and
they i it will be worth it i need to
give you
a gaming computer so i can play my green
computer
i can record like trust me it'll be a
good investment i'll give you part of
the revenue oh yeah
that'd be terrible no no no only one can
win
this is horror music hey what the [ __ ]
hi you guys hi what do you guys all have
in common
we are well high school we're all in
high school
what's high school like right now it's
hell yeah
[ __ ] prison holy [ __ ] was high school
held for you ken
no no it wasn't that bad at all i kind
of enjoyed my high school
that means you were the douchebag
no high school was chill for me too like
you know what people always said
what oh i think high school so bad but
don't worry it gets way better no it
doesn't no
no no it does people are still annoying
nothing
changes the game is thousand to one you
decide who leaves with a thousand
dollars
we're going to do four elimination
rounds if you cannot decide
nobody gets the money round one begins
i think we should describe everyone's
situation for us very briefly because we
can't
have one we could do it that way or we
could do like we have competitions
i feel like competitions isn't the best
i just don't want anybody to leave with
their feelings hurt or feeling like
my problems aren't big enough and i feel
ashamed for talking about what i will no
no
you don't know that that's what i would
have said that they should all
discuss their situation this guy has a
[ __ ] 300 dollar belt but is that
gucci
what he got on there no that's that's
alex that's
i'm impressed that you he recognized
that
300 pounds it's 300 pounds
they okay they don't get that they don't
get the thousand dollars because
obviously they don't know how to spend
their freaking money
yeah i wouldn't buy that belt either did
you buy that belt
i bought the belt i got two of them
two of them i had to get different
colors oh so they match your outfits
yeah but i still need a thousand dollars
though please please please
tommy hilfiger shirt jewelry look at
this dude
if somebody says something super
personal that they wish they hadn't said
because they didn't end up getting the
money
and it didn't help them you know that
could feel like really bad or people can
feel like ashamed about their problems
or like my problems aren't as big as
somebody else's problems
what i would do to 1 000 is help start
uh online clothing business what kind of
clothing will you be selling
just like t-shirts and more like
streetwear oriented
wow he seems like he really thought out
his business plan i think
the money i would invest in that here's
a thousand dollars
you seem to given this a lot of fun i
don't know i guess i'll sell like
t-shirt i mean fair enough people wants
to be a young entrepreneur like
that's not a bad reason yeah yeah i mean
shoot point me in the direction of like
a
clothing company that i can start for a
thousand dollars please
hey you gotta hustle you gotta hustle i
want the one thousand dollars for me so
i can buy another belt
three more belts are those balls
diagonals
oh how do you recognize all this
yeah they're [ __ ] oh how much are
those shoes 750 dollars
i've never even seen shoes that cost 750
dollars holy crap he
figured by the shoes and he can buy the
belt that'd be sick
i'm in full ib so for each test that you
take
you have to pay a certain amount he has
to pay for his college is that what he
said
all right fine fine i just want to put
the money towards college people
but they all have to pay for college
right unless they get scholarships that
give them a free ride
freaking you know tommy he'll figure
dude back there he's not going to pay
for anything he's taken care of you know
we got his chain on it's probably got
diamonds on it probably
got gold in his ass himself start
digging
get a gucci boat or something but gucci
belt
christmas mary like showed me this gucci
belt she wanted like snakes that make
like the g
and she showed it to me like months and
months ago she's like oh it's really
expensive it wouldn't make any sense to
get it but i really like it
[Laughter]
your boy was a hero on christmas got a
gucci yeah
he needs more gucci belts actually i i'm
taking like a couple classes
in my high school that has college
credits towards it
and it's like a good six hundred dollars
i need the other 400 because
my sister like handed me down her car
but like
you have a car did you have a car when
you're in high school yeah i did
what the [ __ ] you were more privileged
than i was
what i didn't have a car in high school
i wasn't able to take the bus everyone
has to drive where i live there's no
public transportation
at all oh okay all right yeah i'm fine
my parents got me a really cheap car so
that they didn't have to wake up and
take me to school i just had to get up
and do it on my own
if you if you had a car in my house go
you were the [ __ ] man like that would
be insane
really but i guess yeah yeah that would
be crazy
one guy had one of these like uh they're
not even cars
yeah yeah yeah it was like one of these
[ __ ] ones
yeah yeah yeah and i was like what the
[ __ ]
people pulled up on that it was like
damn
damn imagine like
this is the [ __ ] [ __ ] in my mind cool
yeah so most of my money would go to
like paying my car insurance and my like
school
in florida whatever i had left over i'd
try to get a good plane ticket over
there
so i could be at the wedding i want to
be a marine biologist when i grow up
i love the ocean i love animals it's
just where i get my happiness from
really
there's this trip to the bahamas which
is very very expensive and a thousand
dollars would help me go to that
i feel like it'd be super cool
experience is it like a trip through
your school
or like no so it's just a personal
interest thing yeah
okay so you just want to go to [ __ ]
bahamas
yeah the bombs would be real cool if i
get that money to go on vacation guys
[Laughter]
but i also want to be a marine biologist
and they got some water there marie
there's they got really nice ocean there
yeah
we got water this isn't very well
fair why did they just lie i feel like
that's what i would have done
legitimately you just
what was your story do you have a story
i i was kind of
sociopathic when i was younger i was not
gonna lie like i probably would have
just said like yeah
like my grandma
my grandma's died and left me a great
deal of debt i need this money
she transferred debt to me and like
i have to work every hour of the day
and i need a pair of yeezys uh i just
need that belt
that would really help the situation
okay just so we're not laughing like i
remember when i was starting off youtube
like i couldn't even
afford buying food so yeah okay yeah i
struggled
for like a couple months guys it almost
feels a rough couple of months
it was really good longest months of my
life
the school that i go to um they don't
supply buses to my
house area so i have to take ubers like
everywhere and it's like
that's expensive yes it's like i need
the americans perspective here
she wants the money so she can take
ubers uh that's a little odd how the
[ __ ] does that make work
what how does she go to a school where
their school buses don't reach where she
is
that's what i want to know what does she
live like the mountains or something
there's oopers in the mountains so
get that hustle man you know
like a lot of stress on me and it's like
oh oh sorry i'm getting emotional
it's like i'm being forced she cried she
gets the money there it is
that's all i need a little emotion i
gotta take
ubers to school
like sometimes they talk to me oh my god
they're really
tired sometimes they don't have like the
free water in the console for me to
drink
[Music]
[ __ ] oh god to transfer three times and
walk for hours
up a mountain both ways in the snow i
have to answer a wisdom three riddles to
pass on
you complain about ubers were you the
one that said we shouldn't do what we
just did
yes why i don't know i think it can make
people feel like their reasons aren't
good enough or
automatically make people feel like well
we should give her the money or give him
the money for this reason or that reason
and not to say that that isn't valid but
everybody else is also valid and so i
think if we decided through like a
random competition
that's a way that nobody could feel
attacked or feel hurt by specific people
i feel like i think that's a pretty
adult response for a high schooler
you don't think so i don't know it's
kind of like i don't think
everyone's actual reasons they need the
money is important we should just have a
competition
because i'm a little more athletic than
everyone here
but i thought she made like a random
lottery or some [ __ ] like we just pick
one and then
then it's done right yeah yeah i mean i
guess so it's like you know i don't
it's the she's she's concerned about the
emotional too
but i guess like maybe people have
reasons they don't want to disclose on
camera of why they want the money or
something i don't know yeah i think i
think she's just playing it she's like i
don't want people to
have better reasons than me so we
shouldn't do that because
no she's a slick one
she's a con artist she knows she knows
she doesn't have a good reason as
everyone else so she
no i i don't know i thought it was great
it's good it's good it's good i feel
like
yeah give it to the person who needs it
because
if she's working really hard and if
she's trying to just get through school
that's a bigger reason than like buying
a plane ticket or
going on a trip or something like that i
don't want it to seem like i'm coming
off like oh i'm using that
that's like i don't want to seem like
i'm like doing what i'm doing but i'm
doing it
that's exactly it the reason why this is
funny because
adults wouldn't be able to do this so
watching high schoolers trying to figure
out like who deserves more money
it's just a mess there yeah like there's
no there's no easy way to do this
even if there was yeah full-grown adults
doing this it would still be a mess you
know it
could be a fight there'll be a diss
track at the end of it yeah that's right
i would use that thousand dollars make a
diss track and roast you
losers i don't want anybody to feel bad
like i don't
feel comfortable talking about the stuff
i have going on at home that would make
a difference
like i know we all have stuff going on
that we didn't bring up you have a
minute
and 10 seconds okay guys we need to like
we need to vote okay this is one vote
for me
are they voting for to who vote out or
uh i think so yeah i think they have to
vote somebody off the island here oh
okay
okay i don't know how to spell his name
i'm sorry
uh one for
colleen obviously one for nina
another one for colleen another one for
me and
one for ej so there's a tie yeah how do
you guys want to do it vote again or do
you want them to decide
just vote just vote
i know i'm going to be out somewhere
yeah because you want to go to the
bahamas
i've already lost guys vote again
to be afraid she probably had the
weakest reason yeah well i mean out of
the
the dude back there with the the three
hundred dollar bill i don't even know
what he said
true is true because i don't know
everyone has something against me so
i don't think it's anything else this is
what i didn't want to happen is somebody
gets hurt by what's happening
well but you're saying like everybody
has something against me so if we just
did random competitions nobody would do
that yeah
she was right right they're already all
pissed off
i like how she has like no like she
doesn't say oh trying to make her feel
better she's like oh my god i was right
see use this girl as an example listen
to me now
listen to me let's just vote i mean i'd
be the same if this happened
to be fair i have one for college
one for jordan two for college three for
college
and one for jordan [ __ ] your business
colleen
you get your t-shirts out of here yeah
everybody's doing it
a thousand bucks dude these kids these
these high schoolers are good dude that
that girl just like just started like
getting upset and so somebody didn't
vote for her because they felt bad
oh [ __ ] you noticed that that's so true
yeah
i just smoked i don't care anyway
you guys ready yeah yes right all right
we've started i feel like we should do
something fun you know something to
bring up the mood
i think we should just do random stuff
like who can name the most countries in
europe who can stand on one foot the
line i'm just saying random stuff
that would be zero americans know
nothing geography
yeah that's true that's i don't even
know like where things are in america so
i don't know we should just like like
mention
all the different uh blocks in minecraft
or like just like
whatever oh my god oh my god should we
do that
first are they doing the mr beast
challenge right here
whoever can stand the longest kids a
thousand dollars
now they're thinking like a youtuber i
am actually really [ __ ] good at this
that would be all aboard this [ __ ] with
you with your cooked knees you're able
to
stand in one foot
they've suffered some injuries in the
past but yeah i'm like making still
staying
couch
i'm buddhist everybody sorry it's like
10 times a day
i'm booties everyone so i do these 10
times a day oh my god
next she's going to tell us how vegan
she is and she does crosstalk
i don't want to be mean they're like
just kids right that's why people are
here watch this video
we gotta be mean all right we gotta be
mean
my favorite part about this whole thing
right here is like doing glasses here
he's like had this like unimpressed face
this whole time he's just like yeah he
doesn't look like he wants to be there
he's like i'm about to get that i'm he
he's
he's he's getting a thousand dollars
he's the sleeper he's being quiet i like
him
okay you got your favorite yeah just to
like throw you guys
off how about you guys have to like spin
around oh
it feels easier
anything else we can do what are we
doing all right how about you stop
since i don't know if you guys are dizzy
it's got like the like the anime thing
going up like the the very high stairs
and like the
the picture out sounds like a foot on
the ground everyone's training standing
on one foot
10 times a day now you do
a thousand times a day
how do you feel do you think that was
fair doing the no
you agreed to it ah
you were the first one to say yes okay
no i lost that was not fair
why did she think it wasn't fair like
who had the advantage there
you better think she had the advantage
oh that's so funny
no it was nina's fault it was her fault
her fault
all right i want to see why she thinks
it's unfair
no did you say no no it's not fair
i don't think anybody had like an upper
hand in that don't be hella mean
i'm v so mean whoa whoa what
drama let's make it interesting so we're
not going to listen to the couch right
guys
who's the leader here nina i feel like
it's the three of us
oh but she's right i think nina is the
leader here because she's i yeah she's
not wrong
yeah well just just in general like
social situations like this like whoever
just talks the most and the loudest kind
of default becomes a leader even if
they're like you know
stupid not trying to yeah there's a
thing in every group there
there's automatically a leader and then
when there's two people competing
against us there's always tension i
think that's why she got so pissed off
as well
because she got out because of her even
like take like uh when we play like a
mungus you know like whoever just like
talked the loudest and the most
everyone starts listening to even if
they have no idea what they're talking
about
that's so true yeah it never changes so
there you go there if you're in high
school and you're trying to figure out
how to become a leader just talk a whole
lot
just don't shut up you may be annoying
but everyone just listen to you
yeah you can be the biggest piece of
[ __ ] in high school they just talk
enough and people will listen
yeah actually that applies for
everything it does yeah
it does is it cool if we stop getting
input from the couch for a little bit
because this is between
inconclusion us five they sort of mine
these are just kids by the way like
yeah it's even like the the high school
like popularity dynamics starting to
kick in can we just
not hear the people on the couch they're
they're right
yeah they're losing yeah they are being
loud though but still
what are you gonna do with the money for
your girlfriend i was gonna take her out
probably to the night's dinner
if he needs it for his girlfriend then i
think his girlfriend would have been a
better candidate to come on the set but
that's the thing like
oh god that was like one part of his
whole thing
something about someone he's got a car
my reason
like i have to pay for school stuff but
the reasoning underneath that
is that like my family also can't pay
for it and it's stuff that i like nobody
knows and like i'm not allowed to talk
about
so i literally like even though i want
to use it as a reason
because it is valid like i can't but
you'd
be okay but she didn't you just didn't
though but i understand where she's
coming from
like you know we all have like super
really big reasons that i can't tell you
that are real you're not buying it no
i'm not buying it look at that do you
think they're just lying
there's a thousand dollars in the line
of course they're lying
so can we think of anything else we can
do that's like i think it's vote coming
out
red light green light get someone out
now
i want to go to the bahamas you want to
do something physical something like a
quiz
that quiz sounds pretty yeah we can do
like a quiz on
ocean facts ocean jesus christ
nj nj oh that's easy oh that's ej sorry
oh that's confusing
yeah nj ej wait who's who
elasticity oh my gosh ej
oh man all right you're really nice i
really like you
ej come join us you didn't do anything
we voted you off
but you just kind of sat there so yeah
we're keeping this guy right here though
because we got tommy hilfiger on you
know what i'm saying
well the popular girls are pruning the
the area here
they're they're taking over yeah the
guys are out any minute
how are you doing it sucks
think of something fun creative dude i
just i just realized something how about
this yeah this this is this this is
literally like the high school
popularity chain we're watching
i mean not to talk trash about these
kids on the couch but they're not as
like physically attractive i don't think
you know in my opinion as the people
that are still on the couch
i think they're literally voting on who
they think is like pretty
at this point
[Laughter]
i mean that's usually how kids think
isn't it yeah it's true all right let's
have a drawing contest then sure and
then are we voting or who's voting
let's have the couch no because they
have their preferences no
because she hates me you like me don't
do that
i mean fair i wouldn't push for that
either i'd be like no the couch can't
speak
actually that's too bad
i mean how are they gonna vote amongst
themselves you have to pick between two
no but you shuffled it so we don't know
whose it is all right that's fair
we'll let them decide draw like an
octopus okay
girl really likes her fish huh yeah yeah
yeah she's sticking to her story
god dang it oh i messed up already
how do you mess up an octopus i'll play
like rock paper scissors together
i'm chilling oh she's getting shut down
on all right it's getting more and more
painful as it goes
i feel bad for her it's like um i think
it's fair to just say like no
i don't wanna but also if i had to go
back in time
i mean this would not happen either way
i'd probably get [ __ ] annoyed anyway
but
i would try and be nicer to people like
this are very
eccentric right right right yeah i get
you because i have little patience
in general and i think especially as a
kid but i think as
you grow older you you tend to be nicer
to people that are
just don't be mean to her okay that's
what i'm saying yeah
she's just a kid i feel bad because
she's trying to lighten the mood after
crying isn't that that's it
she's like oh i feel bad and then she
just gets shut down right away
i i think that's why that's kind of
painful to watch
that's cute it has a little flush and
little kawaii cheeks
ellie the octo is hungry they don't even
get to see them
what did you see that octopus like
no i didn't look look look at what she
holds it up
it's freaking like a like a heart anime
look at that thing what the [ __ ] is that
jesus christ i like it that deserves to
win
and then this one it's another little
creepy one but
you know it's all right actually the
eyes are kind of on point though because
they do kind of come out
so the one that we picked i already see
it or the loser
is the scary one okay i'm out
oh i'm sorry i'm so sorry for this last
run we should like you know
obviously state our opinions do you guys
want our opinions or no
no this is unless we don't like know
that they're singing one of us out or
something then i think that's fair
i don't know why she's so paranoid about
it
[Laughter]
don't take it as like pity like they're
pitying me it's like if you need it you
need it like
i would also say heather i honestly
think that she needs it
really heather needs to ride ubers yeah
like she's like over there trying to not
smile about it's like
at home idiots
i cried over being succeeded in uber
she probably has to ride overs but i
don't know why like it's such
it's weird how we don't get more context
on it i cannot compare myself to what
you two are going through
i live in a city where there's a lot of
things accessible
i have a job you know i have i have
great
supporting parents so i just want i want
to
vote myself off just because you guys
deserve a lot more
than i do i'm definitely going to vote
but
wow the most adult person here yeah damn
that was actually boss move yeah i want
to read the [ __ ] comments so bad dude
it's killing me people people got to be
flaming them so hard that's why they
took them off
people in the comments were probably way
mean than we've been yeah
yeah that's the thing and if you're
watching this don't be mean
just be a that's the thing yeah the real
chat is like when you notice people like
this that maybe
have some i don't know anxiety or
whatever insecurity or whatever
it's better to just i guess it's like
yeah some people grow up a little
later than others there's no reason to
act like down on them just because of
that
right like a real charge that would just
be to be nice to them i think
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah if i could
change one thing
from going back and be nice to the
people i don't know like so
be a chat and be nice okay yeah so like
specifically what are you gonna use the
money for because i know you have like a
lot of stuff going on
i would primarily use it for a car
because
the main thing is transportation yeah
this freaking girl has sat there this
whole time
and been like we shouldn't talk about
the specifics because we got big things
going on then she's gonna sit here and
be like
so tell me exactly what you're going to
use the money on what you got going on
behind
tell me everything i'm not going to tell
you anything about what i got going
specifically but you tell me exactly
what you got going on because it's all
very important now the money's on the
line
i mean now that you don't have a choice
do they they've gotten so far dude do
not give
she's don't give that girl the money i i
hope uber girl gets the money at this
point because screw everyone
really yeah i i prefer the girl on the
right yeah
she's super she's like the most
manipulated person on this couch dude
we can't talk about the specifics but
you better tell me the specifics right
now i'm not going to tell you mine first
we're not even going to acknowledge how
the girl just voted herself she saw it
coming that people would get upset and
mad and [ __ ] it didn't so bad they
removed the comments like
she was right dude i bet i bet the
comments are off because the freaking
girl on the right is gonna get the money
and everybody lost their [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you just don't get ubers i don't get it
i don't get it what did she do before
uber was a thing
yeah how old was she before ubers came
around oh god can you get a vest bar or
like a scooter or some [ __ ] like
just get one of these bad boys that's
what i did oh man
that's the [ __ ] nice one dude i'm 60
bucks you're good
imagine how cool she'd be riding up to
school in that
way cooler than an uber let me tell you
that she would need a thousand dollars
for therapy
sessions after showing up in that oh my
god hey i did
that was nothing wrong look how you
turned out
exactly 35 bucks then
it's big
that's awesome all right let's see it's
got once
this really shows how old we are dude
mine didn't have a stand
[ __ ] privileged kids stand on them
good
i remember mine was so bad that like if
you break too much the wheels would just
scatter off like eventually you would
have no back wheels so there's like a
whole track in the wheels
yeah i can if you went downhill it was
better to just keep going instead of
breaking
oh my god to my struggle we are so much
struggle we're so boomer you're
struggling like you complain about uber
you just get yourself a a luxe transport
scooter it's easy you know
no one would ever do this yo
[Music]
bruh what's the problem that's the
problem explain to me
and explain what the problem is there's
no there's no problem with this bicycle
it's perfect
she did she just want to roll up in
ubers i'm not buying that [ __ ] if you're
not buying the other girl i'm not buying
the super [ __ ]
she lives far enough away to where she
can't ride the bus to school then how
are you going to expect her to bike
across
15 miles of school all right all right
all right google maps
all right all right she lives then she
lives in [ __ ]
okay i'll be unbiased i'll pick a random
spot in america
okay we'll settle this she lives in
kansas nobody she lives in the next
person
and she gotta go to mount drive oh my
god there's one person in the comments
in this video right now being like
that's where i live bro
she got a real thing for newton that's
33 hour
minutes car what is that as an uber
right she said ten dollars
how much is a ten dollar uber right
we'll solve this
we'll solve oh my god we're going deep
okay okay
the cost per mile is two dollar okay so
five miles
trips is what she's making all right so
that means she's going from mcpherson
this is where she lives to how far is
galva
elementary school
[Applause]
she's going from macpherson to galva how
long is that that's 7.5 miles
right that's a 10 minute car ride and
that's giving some leeway too right
okay okay okay all right take that with
a bike oh
that's 40 minutes okay i was completely
wrong never mind
exactly [ __ ] all right all right
i'm back in 45 minutes give her the
money
i was wrong
[Laughter]
i'm going to give it to heather if you
are pretty cool with that
you did it ken you did it i guessed it
but i did not guess that girl on the
right
would vote for i told you she's nice
no she's not the other girl on the couch
was showing her up by being nice and she
didn't want her to steal her thunder so
she's like yeah
i also think that
some people do acts of kindness ken not
everything has an alteration
like everybody everybody that donates to
freaking charity tweets about it okay
and look even marine girls look at
they're all happy oh they're so happy
they did it
thank you for the thousand dollars but i
mean to be fair like if she just
did this right four times
that the bike will pay for itself uh
that's all i'm saying
we got you hey uber girl if you're
watching uh
i'll link you an ebay ad that i found
with bike
you've done the research you're doing
her a favor
this one's been sold 500 times oh my god
that's a good one it's got removable
stabilizers this is what i had
uh piaggio ciao this is one you had one
of these nice
i have one of these bad boys is that a
muffler on there good god
yeah and the muffler broke so it was so
[ __ ]
loud dude like you could hear me from
miles away this is actually pretty cool
you had one of these for real
shut up you're just faking it no i think
i think it's pretty i think it's pretty
all i'd ride this thing
how far did i have to go to school oh
that's a 10 minute bike ride
okay maybe maybe my experiences
with my other kids i thought it was
really far in my head in my head it was
super fun
all right like cut cut all that [ __ ] all
right
people keep all the stuff where i look
good okay
i proved myself wrong she deserves it
clearly
um thank you ken for joining me on this
video it's fun reacting
how was the pleasure i hope i get to
come back again someday i it took an
hour
well time wise we need to do better if
we do but yes
absolutely that's just how much fun it
was okay
it was fun yeah smash like subscribe
we're trying to beat myself in
subscribers so every subscribe
count every sub i get i will donate to
charity
at some point
an undeclared undisclosed amount and
i'll disclose them out
and i'll give an xbox to someone wow